[Music]
and we're back before we went to
commercial break we left our friend
Jordan here making a very important
decision he is going to decide what
barber gets his clippers now back in my
day we didn't get to decide you just got
in the chair and when he was in it
you took whatever tools they had they
had a knife and they used it to shape
I've been coming to this shop for quite
some time now and I've been trying to
decide upon the different barbers how
this one of the hardest things I've ever
had to do ILD because y'all want some
CDs I'm joshing the show boy if you
don't get out of here with your CD ROMs
and your downs get the hell out but you
have the know who do the shooting the
show module Lamarr you give great cuts
excellent lineup some of the best that
I've ever had in my entire life but
honestly man I really don't appreciate
how you keep recording the back of my
head and putting in our Instagram y'all
don't [ __ ] with it that's the thing when
you take the video and you put it on
Twitter I'm sorry what you take the
video you put it on twice on what old
[ __ ] it yo I just like a digital
business card no it's not
Daniel now you give me great advice and
you always know the right things to say
but it takes you like two hours to cut
my hair cuz you're always on that damn
phone always over yo what's good it was
important no wasn't Darryl now your
chairs in the front of the shop so now
what you ain't gettin slippers man why
not oh you know why you know what
appreciate it
you are bak [ __ ] hey what y'all want you
know can I get a Philly steak yeah can I
get the turkey burger no bacon mm-hmm
let me get a one large chicken teriyaki
got it
yeah let me give him number seven um you
know what I'm gonna get nothing just
some I want to do what I did to the bear
from last week when I did it you know
you want anything
ah dude no I'm good all right why don't
you know Jonathan you are by far one of
the meanest people that I've ever come
in contact with in fact you scared me
sometimes yo you really be intimidating
me cuz you a [ __ ] well thank you now
the person that I've decided to give my
clippers is
oh sorry wrong place guys guys come on
guys guys come on um how you doing young
tenderoni let me talk to you a second to
get my clippers it was one of you three
guys got here cut my hair everyone leave
her girl never mess up here so wait wait
wait wait
[Music]